[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video we are going
to talk about a few very new but also
very popular Game of Thrones series
George our Martin might not have
released the means of entering 2018 but
it did release a 700 page history of a
Targaryen dynasty entitled foreign blood
the first of a plan the two-part series
one of the big reasons behind the book
success are the tiny hints of how a song
of ice and fire might end including a
new prophecy that might be about ginjury
ever since Brienne of Tarth executed
Stannis Baratheon at the end of Game of
Thrones Season 5 thus ending the line of
trueborn Baratheon's fans started to
wonder if ginjury the bastard son of
King Robert Baratheon could be
legitimized there's also theory that
King Jim might already be legit my son
assemble if he's the black haired boy
that Cersei claimed that died and Cersei
on the other hand is dangerous blond
hair mother he remembers thus far
nothing like this has happened or came
true but now the ginjury is back in the
story fans are wondering if he could
have a bigger role to play in the great
war that is upon Westeros that brings us
to far in blood George RR Martin's
history of the Targaryen dynasty foreign
blood is told from the perspective of a
new character monumental archmaester
gilding who is described as crotchety
old academic his history of Targaryen
skumps through multiple primary sources
some of which contradict each other as
they push their own agendas in the
recordings of the news of the day the
chapter the dying of the dragons is
about the dance of the Dragons the
Targaryen Civil War death tour Westeros
apart
early on in the conflict Prince Jake
Harris valerian realized that his side
had plenty of dragons but not enough
writers so he offered lands riches and
night woods to whoever could tame the
beasts these people came to be known as
dragon seeds one of them was to hammer a
guy who has a few things in common big
injury here description of another
bastard who eventually becomes a lord
hammer was a Targaryen bastard born on
the island of Dragonstone the son of a
common blacksmith hammer was a huge man
we had so strong that he was said to be
able to twist steel bars into torx
although mostly untrained in the art war
his size and strength made him a
fearsome foe his weapon of choice was
the war hammer with which he delivered
crushing killing blows in barrel hero
drama Thor wants the mount of the old
king himself of all the dragons
investors son Vegard was older and
larger for all these reasons Lord hammer
as he now style himself became to dream
of crowns
why be a lord when you can be a king he
told men who began to get around
and doc was hurting a camp of a prophecy
of ancient days they said and the hammer
shall fall upon the dragon a new king
shall arise and none shall stand before
him whence came these words remains a
mystery
not from hammer himself who could
neither read nor write but within a few
days every man at humble tone a town in
the reach had heard them obviously
hearing injury don't exactly match but
they share many similarities
they're both bastards their lives simple
blacksmithing
and they have a potential to rise far
above their station he was betrayed and
killed before the end of the dance of
dragons but ginjury story might end up
different don't forget what Melisandre
said to gain jury in season 3 episode 6
you're more than they can ever be
they're just foot soldiers in the Great
War you will make Kings rise and fall
and Sancho was probably referring to his
blood that shields for blood ritual but
what mal Sansa was wrong yet again just
as she was wrong well commencing
standings that he is the Promised One
but if mal Sanjay was right about
ginjury making Kings rise and fall but
means the true meaning but if Kings will
literally rise and fall because of him
as a result of his own acts crook injury
for example caused the fall of the
knight king by either forging
dragonglass weapons or even forging
Valyrian steel sword could the last
living son be brought back to do
something big something that will save
the whole Westeros perhaps also arch mr.
Gildea in the men who wrote fire and
blood points out that hugh undeniably
possessed some Targaryen blood usually
the Targaryen blood is a must right
Dragons or to even come close to then
without being burned alive as a
Baratheon bastard ginjury has a
Targaryen blood since not only is house
Baratheon founded by the bastard hell
brother of King Aegon first Targaryen
orys baratheon but Baratheon centaur
garyun cinder married for years as well
this means the Targaryen blood flows in
the veins of the Baratheon line
as a matter of fact after Robert's
rebellion Robert assume they aren't run
on grounds that he had the best claim
out of all the rebel leaders because he
had their garyun blood to justify
Robert's claim the ministers would later
use his blood ties to House Targaryen
although it was conquest which won him
the throne lungs are short ginjury has
Targaryen blood
this means that ginjury can almost
certainly ride one of the nearest
dragons although it's probably going to
be Jon Snow who is going to ride regal a
dragon named after his father Rhaegar
but it's the prophecy that got us really
interested when the hammer shall fall
upon the dragon a new king shall rise
and none shall stand before him as Game
of Thrones news site' winter's coming
point out one idea is that the prophet's
already played out in Robert
film killed Rhaegar Targaryen with his
war hammer on the Trident I'll sting the
Targaryen dynasty and then ruling the
Seven Kingdoms for over a decade another
idea is that the prophecy has yet to be
fulfilled and that ginjury is the guy to
make it happen
interpreting it literally might gantry
actually kill a dragon with his
Warhammer but if the injury has skilled
blacksmith who now knows that journalist
is the key to killing whites and White
Walkers for just a new Warhammer that
incorporates Regulus then he could use
it to kill Viserion the night Kings
dragon
but if ginjuries Targaryen blood could
help him get close enough to Viserion to
land a mighty blow from his Warhammer
and in Missourians life as a white
Walker after death a new king injury
arises fulfilling the prophecy possibly
or he could just be the one to end the
night King and then support Johnston's
claim to the Iron Throne causing the
fall of one king and rays of the other
could it be that George RR Martin's
foreign blood hides some clues for the
end game of A Song of Ice and Fire and
is in one of them definitely and it's
not just a guess it's been confirmed by
George himself according to Martin
foreign blood has Game of Thrones finale
close very Devane the story of an early
Targaryen years in conclusion the
prophecy of a man who will one day build
a hammer and take her dragon is still
out there unfulfilled even though many
interpreted to mean huge hammer prophecy
as Martin likes to - don't always work
the way those who hear too soon ginjury
has direct descendant of Forrester
Goering blood could he be fated to kill
the neck injury will ganger bid one to
slay a dragon in Game three on season
eights final battle another new and
popular Tyrion bring you in this video
is about wall a new wall going into
season eight most of us see only two
possible outcomes irid Knight King wins
in the long night lasts forever or the
night King is defeated and the limbing
has won in this theory however no one
wins and at the same time no one loses
here basically living in the dead we'll
both survive the game Johnson both will
survive in Westeros let me remind you
what we learned from the official game
intern season a teaser without showing a
single frame of new footage from an
actual show HBO manages to stir up a
thematic teaser that brings together
Fire and Ice in unexpected way the
Starks sigil is displayed directly upon
Winterfell marker becomes completely
encased in ice excluding the head what
this means is that the night king will
win Winterfell and even though most of
the stark man will fall the head of
House Stark will survive battle from
interval probably all the stark children
basically the north will lose the battle
against the knockings army and will be
forced to retreat south or at least
those who survived
the Lannister marker on the other hand
becomes completely engulfed in flames
House Lannister is most likely going to
die out in season eight will Danny burn
Cersei in a red keep
horrible Cersei burn King's Landing moon
wildfire Orvil Cersei finally decided to
join the great war is yet to be seen but
the teaser does imply that the living
fire will hit the dead ice and the other
way around fire a nice race towards one
another freezing and burning all in
their path clashing nearly 3/4 of the
river Trident a place of great
historical significance for Westeros it
was here that Robert Baratheon defeated
John's father Rhaegar Targaryen it was
also here that Dorne stark knelt wegen
Targaryen during Aegon's conquest and it
seemingly here that not a conflict
between Ice and Fire will take place Ice
and Fire collide there and it's
seemingly where the final battle will be
fought the same place where children of
the forest first seal the pact with the
first men also where the dance with
dragons was fought and also where the
Gods is located however Ice and Fire
meet in the middle of the battlefield in
this cryptic look at season 8 and the
collision brings with it a new world
it's poised to the why best Rousey have
basically as ice meets fire a new wall
is born from the collision running
east-west across the middle of the
continent some fans are saying that this
is a wall of obsidian known to the
people of Westeros as dragonglass which
in our world forms from lava from
volcano cools rapidly the going theory
is that this will become a new wall the
old one having been bridged by the night
King and his undead rag amount since Ice
and Fire meet in the heart of the
continent and since an outcome of that
battle seems to beat wall many fans
believe that the game insurance might
end with both sides winning and losing
at the same time none manages to win
both live on their own half of Westeros
with the night king and his army on the
north side and the living in southern
side the new night King's Kingdom would
extend from the lands of always winter
as the broken wall and down into the
river lands no one wins the night King
Annie's army whites and white walkers
get what half of Westeros in the living
gets the are truly bittersweet ending
better that living did not win against
Nat King and many characters died but
still sweet as night king did not win
either and the living did not go extinct
since Regulus is one of few things that
can kill a boy poker the wall made out
of eight would obviously be an effective
way to keep the White Walkers Center
whites from ever crossing into the realm
of the living again of course this
theory takes the symbolism in a teaser
trailer very literally but nevertheless
it's a very popular theory among the
fans personally
I've always believed that Sirius would
then the wall where it all started but I
never expected it to possibly take place
in the new wall it also seems logical
that the wall would be rebuilt after the
final battle had ended this time it
material that would most certainly
prevent from another attack of the net'
king the current Lord Commander add is
the 999th Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch this never struck me as accidental
George Arman is not one for coincidences
when ad passes in the battle against the
night king it means that the next Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch will be
one thousand Lord Commander although who
will be remains unknown with most
popular gases being Jaime Lannister if
he survives send your moment in
conclusion in this new wall would
represent another case of history
repeating itself and just like after the
first long night both sides will survive
and the wall will be created to divide
him only this time the living will have
to give up the entire North's to the
night king not only the northernmost
part of it
the Ginji theory that I introduced to
Bates earlier in this video also sounds
interesting especially begins your
fitting in the prophecy that is yet to
be fulfilled
perfectly let me know if your opinion
about the Ginji theory as well as about
the bittersweet ending of game materials
in the comment section down below and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]